precisamente el presidente de estados
unidos joe biden estaba participando en
este foro organizado por la cámara y
comercio de eeuu con empresarios de
directores ejecutivos de todas las
compañías de eeuu para tratar de
incentivar a que inviertan en
centroamérica y en suramérica con el fin
con dos propósitos del primero de estos
seres atender las causas que originan la
migración hacia el norte del continente
llevar inversión extranjera llevar
inversión estadounidense por supuesto
hacia estos países con el fin de atender
las causas como la pobreza la falta el
desempleo que son las que originan la
migración hacia el norte y también se
buscó incentivar que se produzca
los productos que han presentado escasez
debido a la invasión rusa rusa ucrania
de éstos por ejemplo los fertilizantes y
los alimentos y de alguna manera hacer
pactos con los países de suramérica para
qué
y podamos puedan estos países suplir a
eeuu y no se generen escasez como se ha
generado debido a la invasión rusa en
ucrania